one of the most famous or infamous new
atheists
of the 2000s
uh sam harris the new atheists for those
who don't remember was sam harris
christopher hitchens richard dawkins and
daniel dennett and it was more a
publishing phenomenon than it was a real
intellectual movement but it was a bunch
of guys who said religion is bad and
they did it because they were attacking
islam because
radical islam was a big topic of concern
then after 9 11 and they used the
specifics of islamic terror attacks to
attack religion generally and a bunch of
very shallow thinking teenagers thought
this was really smart i was one of those
shallow thinking teenagers i was really
taken up by it the new atheists have
aged like milk and now the new atheists
are not even being applauded by the libs
because they've transgressed certain
norms of wokeness and
political correctness
but it's worth remembering these guys
doc hitchens is dead but dawkins dennett
and
sam harris
these are even though they sometimes
contradict political correctness they
are men of the left sam harris just
proved this when in an interview he said
look
yeah it's bad that the
liberal oligarchy twitter and big tech
it's bad that they covered up the hunter
biden laptop story and they censored the
new york post and they stopped people
from messaging the story which was
damaging to the bidens to one another
that's bad but you know look it was to
stop trump so yeah sensor away
at that point hunter bind literally
could have had had the corpses of
children in his basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing first of all it's
hunter biden right it's not it's like
it's not joe biden but
even if joe like even the whatever scope
of joe biden's corruption is like if you
if we could just go down that rabbit
hole endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in now that's not that
doesn't answer the people who say it's
still completely unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
left-wing conspiracy to deny the
presidency to donald trump absolutely it
was absolutely right but i think it was
warranted
it was a left-wing conspiracy it was
censorship it was wrong
maybe it was illegal i don't know
uh but who cares it was all sorts of sin
sinful and all sorts of terrible but it
was worth it
so on the surface this story is not that
interesting wow one of the most famous
atheists in america is advocating
immorality not exactly
a man bites dog story of course the guy
has no real solid
moral foundation he has tried to create
some way of justifying the existence of
objective morality without god that is a
fool's errand that's not possible so
when push comes to shove when it gets to
something he really really wants like
kicking trump out of office he says yeah
the ends justify the means it's immoral
but whatever you know who cares
sure
sure
the bigger takeaway here
is that the libs will do
anything to stop trump and his
supporters even sam harris
sam harris by today's standards is one
of the more moderate libs and even he
says yeah
do anything to stop trump because they
called trump hitler they said trump is
hitler trump is the embodiment of evil
and so if they use that kind of language
for trump and his supporters and you and
me folks
and anyone to the right of hillary
clinton if they use that kind of
language then of course they will do
absolutely anything to stop us we can't
be surprised when people who kill the
babies and trans the kids and rig
elections and censor all sorts of
material and who admit that these things
are immoral when they do those sorts of
things we cannot be surprised there's
nothing they won't do to stop the evil
orange man right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles
regardless of what the biden
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried they're feeling it
food and gas prices are higher than i've
ever seen in my lifetime that is why i
am so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers an
inflation-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe i don't know how this works i
hope good ranchers can stay in business
this is such a good deal
you you subscribe right now you can
either buy a box of meat
absolutely top quality meat you just buy
a one-off box and you enjoy it or you
can subscribe and for the whole life of
your subscription it will never go up
do it right now this is the most insane
deal i've ever seen goodranchers.com
knowles use code knolls at checkout you
get 30 bucks off plus free shipping lock
in that price recession proof your meals
for life inflation proof your meals for
life you'll be automatically entered to
win 30 minutes by the way of all access
with me on september 30th if you do that
this offer ends august 31st we're
calling it a meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com at checkout
hey michael
so
i have a funny story that kind of
relates to what you were talking about
in a previous episode
so in 2012 i believe when obama was
running
a
felon from i think it was texas
beat him in
a lot of west virginia counties like it
was 40 60 like it was really close made
me laugh
complete topic change right here my
sister who's been struggling with
infertility
um
we were talking she asked me how i felt
about roe versus wade i said i 110 agree
it shouldn't have even been decided in
the first place like it was great that
it was overturned
and she said
i agree abortion should never be used as
birth control because
you know women are responsible for their
actions right
and then we got to the topic of rape
she said
and i quote if i went out today
got raped and got pregnant
me being infertile
i would 100 no questions ask it an
abortion
that made no sense to me and then she
got really mad at me when i said
execute the rapist don't execute baby
the baby had nothing to do with it
um
so we went back and forth and then she
got really mad at me but
i mean we're still cordial like i'm
close to my sister but
yeah that argument made absolutely no
sense
thank you
a good point yes the argument doesn't
make sense but it's one that i've i've
found a lot of pro-life people and
conservatives stumble on
they get tripped up on when they are
confronted with it which is what about
the case of rape are you telling me that
what if a woman is raped and becomes
pregnant that you would you would make
her carry that baby to term and of
course the number of the percentage of
abortions that take place in the context
of rape it's less than one percent so
it's it's really just a distraction
because the libs don't want to deal with
statistically 100 of abortions which are
elective
so they bring that up and this is the
hard case
and but
the premise here is that
you can
undo the rape you can make the rape all
better you can make the rape go away if
you just kill the baby and that's a
ridiculous premise we should not accept
that premise
the woman is raped now she's pregnant
and confronted with a choice do you kill
the baby or not
the the two questions from the moral
standpoint are completely unrelated
the rape is bad the rape is a trauma the
woman is going to have to work through
that rape
spiritually psychologically perhaps
physically
that's
abortion isn't going to fix any of that
then you have the question should the
woman kill the baby
in addition to that and by the way if
the woman does kill the baby and they're
not going to tell you this in the
pro-abortion lecture or class if the
woman does kill the baby she's going to
have a trauma from that too one she's
going to have to in a sense give birth
to it one way or the other you've got to
get the baby out of there and two she's
going to have the nagging guilt of the
reality that she killed the baby
so you're adding trauma on to trauma
but
even putting that aside for a second
nothing about getting the abortion is
going to in any way change the rape so
you've got to call them out on that you
say yeah i don't think that women who
have been victimized and raped
should then have the additional trauma
of committing a murder i'm so glad you
like that clip now before you go look we
got over a million subscribers i love
that i want a trillion okay and the
first step to a trillion subscribers is
you clicking that bell so ring it click
it ding dong what a what a bing bong
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you